the Joe Rogan experience well you were a
big part of the Blackzilians getting
started yeah and when you had that
opportunity as a guy I was a former
world champion to go there and sort of
get become a part of a team from the
ground up what did you try to do that
was different then had you had seen in
other camps that you had participated in
I wanted to make it just like a you know
the biggest thing back then it was it
was that there was you always had to go
to so many different places in order to
just get that one thing so I war really
wanted to just make us so that our guys
didn't have a need to go anywhere else
for anything else and that was the whole
idea behind the whole Blackzilians you
know we brought in all kinds of people's
from every different aspect from you
know training to to nutrition almost
every aspect of it and that's what we
wanted to provide our athletes with just
like the total the total game so they
really didn't have to do anything to
worry about anything except for showing
up the Train and it worked for a while
it worked for a while but but it's it's
a hard thing to maintain because that's
in a very very expensive thing you know
yes well Glen the guy who put up the
cash I mean I had heard some outlandish
figures that he had was in the hole for
that place for by the time everything
was up and running yeah yeah it was it
was a pretty it was a pretty pretty
hefty ticket man it was a pretty happy
ticket and it was uh it was it was an
expense that it did get out of hand I
take it I'm sure yeah he he and here's
the thing about it like even even his
situation no he got himself in a
situation where he was doing so much for
people it just became a thing that
people expected out of him mm-hmm and
then when he wasn't able to do it
anymore than it was kind of like you
know people are like oh man this guy is
it this and he wasn't that but right he
just he just wanted to do so much and
had an idea to want to do to do things
on another level but at the same time
you know the
the finances of doing it was a massive
undertaking I'm sure I mean all credit
to Dan Lambert because Dan Lambert is
he's in doing this from the beginning
yeah that [ __ ] guy I mean he is the
reason why these super camps got started
at Dan lamp they put his own money and
then the new ATT they built he built
himself from the ground up built the
whole [ __ ] building and you know I
haven't seen in person I have friends
that have come to visit it but I've seen
it in videos and holy [ __ ] it's
phenomenal I went inside of it Dan's the
man yeah it really is
dan dan is a good guy man um you know
after the whole thing with the black
zillions you know him and I got got to
have a chance to spend some time
together and just and just talk you know
there was so much weird animosity it was
within the UFC put that show together
yeah it's like I inherited beef with
people that I didn't even know I didn't
even say hello to him you know that's so
crazy and I just inherited this beef and
I was like you know it's silly and
especially the fact that ATT is like
literally right down the street from my
house they would be closer to go there
than anywhere else but it was weird for
a while but actually talking to Dan and
actually getting to know him and you
know it was a it was a good it was a
good thing because I you know I got I
got to get a lot of respect for for him
and just for what he's done what
American Top Team and ATT in general
know he's a he's a brilliant guy I love
that guy as a person I'm a big fan of
his I just love that a person like that
like Dan Lambert can literally change
the course of MMA by setting an example
yeah and by having a gym that sets an
example that's such an insanely high
level so big so many world-class
fighters there so much strength and
conditioning everything under one roof
dorms everything you wanna say I think
that was that was the thing that that
kind of you know that kind of pushed
things in that in that position for Glen
you know Brian keep up he had to keep up
well he was trying to outdo yeah cuz I
trying to do Dan Lambert I always wanted
to do something that Dan wasn't doing
you know some luck with that
yeah we did go broke that's a good way
to spend a lot of money
yeah yeah there's I mean there's a lot
of super camps out there now it's
interesting to see these places you have
Tristar in Montreal you have you know
Duke Rufus and Milwaukee of Jackson
Winkeljohn and Albuquerque yet aka you
know it's when you first started there
was not that many places now they're
worthy was it and and to even get what
we wanted out of it you know we there's
three gyms that we can go through we'll
go to either Jackson's in Albuquerque
we'll go to Tristar in Montreal who will
go to Denver and we'll work with Trevor
Whitman in Denver so we had the three
camps that we bounced around from and
and that's what we ago to get the most
working it and it worked for a while you
know work for a while for the most part
but just all that traveling it just
became hard to do but that's to wear on
you when you're in the middle of a camp
and you're yeah staying in hotels and
yeah it's like um
like when I was in camp I really
wouldn't travel too much but like when
so what we do is that if if Nate
Marquardt was in camp and he wanted to
stay at home most of the time so we're
staggering we're you know he have a
tough guy and kept every single time so
I'll be a couple weeks when George
wasn't there or when Keith wasn't there
you know and then sometimes we'll all
come together but for the most part
we're just all rotate in to these gyms
depending on who was fighting who need
the work
[Applause]